there's a myth that needs to be busted
amongst many people I think that still
exists out there and pervades across
um you know many societies across the
world is that medicine is an exact
science and it's not an exact science I
say physics or chemistry it's an applied
science it's a science of human beings
human beings are complex human beings
are Dynamic and you know one of the
things we're taught in medical school is
that 50 of what you learn will turn out
to be either outdated or dead wrong
within five years of your graduation the
trouble is nobody can tell you which
half
so you have to learn to learn on your
own and I think one of the interesting
things I noticed during this whole
pandemic which concerned me is Anthony
fauci coming out consistently saying
trusts of science
that's probably one of the most
unscientific statements I've ever heard
in my life
Anthony saying that it doesn't make any
sense it's nonsense there's always an
uncertainty attached to this stuff
things change and evolve and it was this
was um but I think that was exploitation
of people's false beliefs of what modern
medicine does and what modern medicine
can achieve and you know there's no
doubt that mod we've achieved many great
things certainly in acute care
but if you look back over the last
couple of decades
um Brett you know we know for example
from analysis by
um Marcy Angel former editor of neon
medicine between 2000 2008 of the 667
drugs approved by the FDA on the 11 were
found to be truly Innovative 75 were
essentially copies of old ones we've had
certainly in the UK and I think that
it's similar in the US it may even be
getting worse we've had a stalling and
life expectancy for the last decade
combined with an increasing burden of
chronic disease so people are living
longer in sickness so that in itself
should be an indication that there's
clearly something wrong with the medical
system and at the heart of that is this
over-medicated population and lack of
attention to
the simple stuff which is actually
leading a healthy life through lifestyle
um you know good health doesn't we need
to just we need to get this message into
the minds of the American public good
health does not come out of a medicine
bottle
um yeah you this is uh
beautifully said and fits so perfectly
with uh The evolutionary implications
right and you know you you quite
correctly diagnose the problem and I
what the argument I've made is that we
inferred the rules of science from the
simple Sciences from the fundamental
Sciences chemistry and physics because
that's where our big early gains came
and we've misunderstood how to apply it
in the context of a complex system it
doesn't work right if you take the
approach as if it was a simple system
then you might well have the idea that
oh this person has a pathology the
obvious thing to do is to apply a
compound that interfaces with the
particular pathway in which that
pathology emerges but you know if you do
that how many other things are you
interfering with right the chances that
you're going to do that at low cost are
actually surprisingly low and the right
way to deal with these things is almost
always ways to figure out what the what
the source of the issue is and to
correct what you're calling the
lifestyle issue that causes it now
sometimes it's too late and sometimes
you got to take a drug to you know
basically it functions like a corrective
lens but
um but the long and short of it is
Pharma has a perverse incentive to get
us to take more drugs and to think that
that's normal and not only are is the
human being a complex system but it's a
nested series of complex systems you
know in the case of covid you were
dealing with uh the immune system which
is a complex system of its own inside a
human being another complex system
inside a society in which an epidemic is
taking place a third complex that's a
nested series of complex systems the
chances of intervening and you know
coming out way ahead are pretty low
and the chances of your coming out way
ahead if what you do is you intervene on
the basis of some simplistic conclusion
and then you don't track the impact of
it you know the chances are essentially
zero right that was that was going to be
a disaster just from the get-go
[Music]